[Music]
all right hello everyone yeah so today
in the
lesson i'll show you examples of
unconventional creative moves and
well i'll just start by saying that this
is something that
potentially cost me in
winning the us championship not being
able to spot
unusual creative moves
so it's very important to be flexible
minded and
be able to consider all sorts of moves
even those that don't first come to mind
because that will broaden your
vision and at some point that could make
a very big difference in your chess
so we'll start with some relatively
easier puzzles on that
on that topic but um
then we're gonna see some examples from
for my
my u.s championship just now and
you'll see exactly what i'm talking
about so
let's uh
start with uh
this one this one is black to play and
the question is
can black do better than
let's say just recapturing on d4 of
course recapturing on d4 is
kind of a safe solid move but
does black have anything better
and i mean i guess to make it easier for
you there
most of the moves that we're going to be
talking about are a little bit unusual
right so you have you're forced to think
outside the box so i guess in a way that
helps
helps you a little bit obviously during
the game no one will tell you but
um
yeah
okay so someone on youtube also
mentioned bishop e2 yeah bishop b2 is a
very
logical idea but the thing is then of
course white will play rookie one right
and then
the question is how exactly do we follow
up because if bishop c4 there's rook c4
and uh if rook g4 bishop e2 rookie four
it's nothing special again
bishop f1 bishop f3 like anything
so bishop e2
is an interesting try
but
at least in this moment
it's not gonna
you know bring you anything special
but
we
we should have that idea in our reserve
and maybe we can try to play something
to
make that idea stronger some people are
also typing in the chat bishop e6 but
bishop e6 doesn't really have a threat
so even if we play a random move like f3
or rookie one it's
bishop e6 doesn't exactly do anything
it's just hoping that he takes but then
we go 92 but of course
he's not going to take it and then
it's nothing so special
um
so we have to try to actually make a
threat bishop e2 does make a threat to
the rook but he can move the rook away
so
let's try to be creative here how can we
maybe disturb his harmony to
make this move
more powerful
similar idea
if we play rook fe-8 then we'll play i
don't know f3 or rookie one
like it's
he can play many moves to
to kind of
be solid
knight h3 well knight h3 i don't think
doesn't does anything because after
takes
what's the what's the follow-up
f5 yeah unfortunately we can't play a
five because the pawn is spinned but
even if we could you know the night will
move away and doesn't do anything
all right looks like maurice smashley
got the right idea but make sure you
give the
follow-up
to your move don't just give the move
give me the
follow-up that's very important here
so rook d4 is of course a move but the
question of course was specifically
presented is there anything better than
rookie t4
rook g4 is a neutral move but then he
can play
rookie one f3 and nothing special so
so maurice smashley got the move but
sorry
but it's irregular okay see
but uh we need to make sure we find the
follow-up to that move
like if if if he plays the most natural
move
what does block do
yes so we play b5
that's the idea right and after this
we go bishop e2
yes so um
this is the
this is the idea so this pawn move is
very good right disturbs his harmony and
then after the bishop takes
we go bishop e2 and now the difference
the bishop is not protected and he will
lose material no matter what so very
nice creative out of the box thinking
move right which is why we have to be
open minded and considering all of our
checks capture threats so when we see a
move like bishop e2 and you see why it
doesn't work we have to consider okay
maybe we can try to play that on move
two in some in some lines and we have to
be flexibly minded here so
i like this puzzle a lot like out of the
box thinking
um
all right so let's look at the next one
um
all right black to play
what should black do
in this position black has one winning
move if you don't play the winning move
you're losing
so this is uh this is one of these where
you really have to
yes
yep
well
if you take the if you take the knight
then i'll take queen takes and then what
do you want to do
okay but then i then probably take and
you still don't really have big threats
i mean even a b is not a huge threat i
mean i can also play b3
so i don't think you accomplishing that
much it's in this case and you're also
trading off your pretty good bishop here
all right looks like one person on
youtube got it so let's see if
um
anyone okay two people got it okay on
youtube people are starting to get it
uh
so
okay i think we'll gonna start going
over it um so a3 is a a
common choice amongst people um
but the problem is knight c6 and the
thing is a3 does not have a powerful
threat actually surprisingly like white
still
you know
white can also attack a lot of things
and
a3 does not have any real powerful
threats just yet
um
knight g2 yes
if rook c4 rook c4 does not really work
somebody suggested that knight g2 yes we
have to the way we find that move is we
have to just look at all of our checks
capture threats right knight g2 doesn't
seem like the most natural but moving
right away from the center but yet it
just disturbs the harmony right the
queen is becomes overloaded and
white cannot really defend if queenie 2
of course we just go bishop d4 pretty
simple
um
so the queen if queen g3 knight here
also so queen c3 is kind of the only
move to try to hold everything together
and now how does black continue here
i mean with a3
i mean that's true yeah a3 is also
kind of interesting but maybe b3 is not
that bad still here
91 very good
91 is very strong rook b3 somebody
suggested but rugby three
i think uh
even if we do queen b3 it doesn't seem
like so clearly winning
so yes um
i believe 91 is very strong and uh
if rook here then
we play knight takes f3
and queen f3 rook b2 and uh
and that's winning
so black just little by little disturbs
his harmony and makes white's position
um falls apart starting with this very
nice move knight g2 then the rook queen
has to move rook has to move and then
white's harmony is
messed up
all right so now
let's do this one this one is uh white
to play
white to play and win try to give the
whole variation
ah thank you eric
i think i've got it
it's okay give it a shot
bishop d6 um
but bishop d6 actually i don't have to
take right what if i go bishop
rook e6 uh
brook takes e5
yeah i'm not sure because yeah the
queen's hanging yeah
yeah i think uh if i go bishop e6 now
you're suddenly pinned up a little bit
right
it doesn't seem like we want to play
like that
um
knight d6 is
yeah we have to try to give the whole
variation right not just not just one
move but try to give the the whole line
okay so of course the correct move is uh
knight d6
uh that's the most natural move bishop
xd6 now
here
we have a choice we have queen a6 and
bishop takes d6
bishop xd6 looks completely winning
but black has a surprising defense here
what is it
okay i think somebody found the the line
the right cor line dolan i think found
the right idea
so we're not gonna
uh say yet what it is but
first let's try to find the defense for
black here after bishop d6 bishop d6
because yeah here looks like it's
winning queen a6 is a threat and looks
like it's uh
almost no way but black has a fantastic
defense here
after which he's not worse
king b7 does not work because if king b7
check here queen of five will get
overloaded
so we can't go
king b7 unfortunately
so but yeah the move for black here is
very nice the offensive move
also speaking of unnatural moves it's
not the most natural move but
it's
okay
e king master puppets you're right
that's one of these two but which one
there's a big difference
df-8 uh rook df-8 i think you're losing
here this queen a6 check king here is
forced queen a5 check now if king c7
queen queen c8 queen c7 is made you have
to go k8 and then rookie 5.
so unfortunately that does not save us
so yes
aaron is correct we play bishop e8
if we go bishop e6 we also get mated
so actually by process of elimination
it's bishop e8 and amazing enough this
is not clear because if you do this
same thing
amazingly enough
white is lost here
because
our queen is attacked by the bishop
our bishop on a4 is offside
and black has threats black threatens
the queen black threatens rook d6 and
black threatens queen of one and in some
cases black threatens the rook and
white's gonna lose material and lose the
game
so that's just insane queen c4 king
takes d6 and black will escape and he's
up a rook and he wins
now i think white does not have to go
queen a6 i mean i think this line
somehow ends in a draw i don't remember
how but this is why bishop takes d6 is
not the most accurate it looks winning
but amazingly this is bishop e8 defense
right so we have to really
look at opponent set ideas
so the correct line is queen a6 check
of course king b8 loses routinely two
bishop takes d6 king a8 bishop takes c6
so he has to go king c7 queen a7 king c8
and this is where we have this very nice
unnatural move that i want you guys to
try to see if you can find white of
course can is guaranteed to draw here
queen check here here and black cannot
go here because of mate right so white
is guaranteed to draw
but white wants more than the draw
what is the only way white can get more
than the draw i think somebody on
youtube already found it but let's see
if anyone else finds it
it's just again it involves disturbing
opponents harmony to makes the threat
and
at the same time we disturb opponents
harmony it's a very nice idea
you
very good uh yes
the correct idea is the brilliant bishop
b5
if takes queen a6 and now we
yeah because the diff we got rid of that
pawn right we disturbed their harmony
with our pawn on c6 holds everything but
we get rid of that pawn and then we set
up the mate so bishop v5 has three
purposes we're threatening mate we're
trying to get rid of this pawn and we're
more importantly we're stopping queen of
one mate that's why i was looking at it
because
it seemed like the only thing but i
think yeah because after cb we have this
brilliant queen e6 and and white is
winning
which is fantastic
idea so so we have to be flexibly minded
right a lot as you can already see very
often we have to consider these moves
that may be sacrifices
disturb his opponent's harmony because
by doing that we might give up a pawn or
even a piece but we break something in
opponent's coordination and as a result
we can accomplish
what we want so disturbing opponent's
harmony is like a very important
important theme in chess
all right now this one
white to play and uh
and win
how should white
um how should white play
again this is all i'm giving you
challenging stuff because i know that
um on youtube a lot of very strong
players are watching and and so
that way
there's a little bit of something for
for everyone
so two more puzzles and then i'm gonna
show you
my
unfortunate moments in the u.s
championship which basically cost me the
the title
but
let's do these ones first and then we'll
get there
so h7 looks very natural actually in my
opinion it does not look natural and for
one specific reason this bishop on g6 is
horrible right wouldn't you rather play
rook g7 and trap it and then just
promote the pawn the problem with
playing h7 is that after takes takes
uh i think we're only trying to lose
here right because after the pawn goes
to a3 king b4 b5
our king is this king is stuck with
these pawns right and uh our rook is
busy stopping our point right so i think
we're only trying to lose and probably
we are losing here
so this is definitely not the way we we
want to play now rook g7 is of course is
very tempting but the problem is what
you're going to do after a3
that's what you have to calculate
because if we take here
and then we go a2
this one also stops our pawn right and
then we we're gonna get made it
and this is not gonna be good
all right looks like roberto
molina got wait
i think this is an
international master right i think if
i'm not mistaken or maybe there's maybe
he's
maybe there's a
another person with the same name
i could be wrong
um
i thought
oh yeah yeah that's that's you okay
that's him okay yeah because i heard
this name before yeah that's
see i i i told you guys there are some
very strong players
here so uh
okay uh so we have an i am in the house
watching live
that's that's good so you guys
have
a
tough competition
okay so
yeah so here's the here's the point of
this problem right so
rook g7 is the move you really want to
play but after a3
um
we cannot take that
and if we go back rook a7 this is still
not quite winning because after okay six
[ __ ] page seven rook here we go king c3
and uh this is going to be a draw like
we're not going to be able to win this
all we can do is we keep keep checking
checking checking but it's going to be a
draw so the idea here is we actually
play rook a7
putting black and zuk's wing and why is
the zoox when you may ask well let's see
the bishop can't move these black pawns
can't move if the king goes anywhere
like c6 or something we lose the a4
point so the only move that does not
lose material is king b4 but now
what we can do is a brilliant move look
back to g7 so we it seems unnatural why
are we forcing the king to go to b4
where it wants to go anyway but the
difference is now we go here and after
this we've disturbed their harmony
because after this look we go rook check
we have this check now because the king
is on before
and after here
we go back and then we stop the spawn by
with the check and we win the game so
sometimes we can literally lose a whole
tempo like that in an end game just to
disturb their harmony and just to
improve our coordination so
fantastic
okay
so let's um
okay this this one will be kind of
challenging so but since we have an im
here that's actually good this
hopefully this is going to be
a good one
i think i think this will be actually
what we'll see unless he knows this one
so why to play white to play and win
i mean this is a very hard one but if uh
but i just think it kind of shows a very
nice there's a nice very nice point to
it i think it's
aesthetically beautiful which is why i
kind of
wanna
um
wanted to show this one this is actually
from the variation mark
varietsky um
so why to move and win i mean there are
many ways we can probably get the draw
but we're trying to win here
you know what's funny i think one person
had had the answer correct and he's and
then he says uh
and then i think he kind of corrected
himself and uh actually he had the right
move the first time
it's kind of interesting i don't want to
say yet who it is but
all right that looks like one person got
andre
fidalgo
um
maybe he's also a
uh
a masked
i am or gm uh
so
yeah so the thing is okay there are many
ways we can try if we go rook g1 we can
go
ah nmic
we can yeah then there's queen d4 or
queen c3 and and stuff like that
and it's not so clear please don't spam
on the chat
um
and um
if we play rookie six
king here
h5 king g8 the queen also starts um
escaping right so another move that we
can try is rook f2 but still after queen
d4 or queen c3 black gets a lot of
counter play
so the brilliant point here is that we
have this move rook one e5
um insane move um
we give up the rook
but after de we go rook f2 and uh
we go check and we win the queen and
because black's beautiful friends his
pawns the queen's friends
are are stopping uh the queen's escape
route black will lose the queen for the
rook and the point is white has this
pawn majority on the queen side and he
will play a5 b6 and win the game and
that was another very important thing to
pay attention to to realize that if you
actually can exchange two rooks for the
queen
you're winning so this was uh it was not
this is actually a puzzle this is not a
i don't think this is from a real game
this is a
this is just a puzzle
all right
now from real games you might think
these things are only relevant from the
puzzles but you'll see five examples of
mine where i missed very nice
opportunities and you'll see how why
it's important to be creative
so first of all good memory well mixed
memories so this is from the us open
that i won right you know in august
right before your championship
i got eight and a half out of nine but i
came this close to getting
breaking history and getting nine out of
nine
um and this was like my game last round
game against benjamin gledura a grand
master who lives in saint louis right
now originally from hungary
and
and then i kind of outplayed him at some
point i got a very good end game
and and here in this position he offered
me a draw and a draw clinched me clear
first
uh so
you know i thought for about seven
minutes
i didn't find a clear way to win like i
was looking at several ways i knew i'm
probably at least slightly better but i
didn't quite realize um that i'm
completely winning here
um and the winning idea here is actually
very unusual very creative and somehow
it never even crossed my mind and my
opponent immediately told me after the
game that about it and how it was it was
winning and
yeah it's a big pity that i didn't i was
not open-minded and also i kind of feel
upset that i didn't pay attention to
this weakness of mine after
the the us opened because i could have
worked on that before u.s championship
and maybe my result in the u.s
championship
would have been different but you know i
guess you live you learn and um
everything happens for a reason so
anyway without further ado
try to find the best idea here for black
uh black's black's plan and yes i am
reading the chat so you guys could
suggest your
your ideas
and so please say nice things here
all right looks like kibitzer's chest
castling got it
so so far we have one guy who got a
correct idea um we have one idea
one person said d4 one person says c4
and we have also bishop xf4
so all of these are pretty natural moves
like i considered all these moves that
were
okay one other person got the right
answer mr balhats
ah
hi um
good good day mr
mr villaflores
um
okay so let's go over the most natural
possibilities first um
so i i consider d4 but then i thought um
if d4 then
you can uh
play c4 or even take and king e2 and i
thought
it's not so easy the pun is
it's getting located or even c4 maybe
it's possible move i was also
considering c4 but c4 knight before
bishop takes pawn takes
king here king there and the problems if
i ever go king c5 he checks me away
and um
it's not so easy
i was mostly looking at king c6 and the
idea is king e2
then i wanted to take that
and uh no sorry i wanted to take on d3 i
was considering taking on d3 then
calling king b5 but his king kind of
just gets there in time to c2 and
it's a good winning chance but it's not
quite
quite winning um
and i thought okay it's
it's no big deal um
i didn't see a clear win so i just said
okay let's make a draw
uh i should have of course spend more
time and look be more more open-minded
than just being more try to look more
for creative options
and yeah if i did that maybe i would
have had a chance but the thing about
creative moves is that
you are the only way you can find them
is if you look for them right otherwise
they're not going to just come to your
head right you have to force yourself to
look for them
that's the thing about chess and i think
the way you get better is doing studies
and seeing yourself more these puzzles
and then you're more likely to be
flexibly minded to find that
the correct idea is a brilliant um
h5
and uh
the point is you want to play h4 h3 you
make a pass pawn right and then once you
make a past pawn you're going to have
two pass points at some point d4 as well
and then you're not going to really be
able to hold the position
and the problem is after king e2 h4 he
cannot take on d5 because we go h3 and
the pawn's unstoppable
the pawn is literally unstoppable
and of course if he ever takes it then
there's c4
so some but somehow this idea of h5h4 h3
just never crossed my mind like somehow
this move seemed
unnatural to me like putting the pawn on
three like that but
once you go over it it's actually a very
logical move and of course if i find
that move it's almost certain i winning
the game it's minus four minus five
something like that on the engine
he's more or less losing the knight yeah
he's uh that's kind of almost the best
line for white like he really cannot
he cannot do anything to
to save the
the game anymore
so i and i think my opponent even said
that he was going to give up tonight
somehow
what's a good source to find studies
puzzles to build the ability to find
creating moves yeah i think that's
something that i probably can answer
maybe in in a week or two because that's
something i've also asked a few other
people but i think so far the answers
i've got are um
maybe the variety and agarth those are
be the
the really challenging uh guys to study
i think variety has a lot of these kind
of creative puzzles and unnatural ideas
so maybe maybe the variety
why can't c4 well c4 it's uh
it's not really winning right because
take stakes king d6 king g2 as i already
mentioned king goes to g3 and if you try
to go king c5 d4 then here
if you go um if you go h5 king e1
no sorry 90
91 yeah then the difference is that
after this
you bring the king to c4 and you're
gonna make another pass pawn
and uh
and white will not be able to defend
both weaknesses you know in chess
there's a something called principle of
two weaknesses right you have to create
sec two weaknesses to win the game and
here you um
white cannot defend against all the
weaknesses like in the long run this b2
is very weak this pawn you have to worry
about this pawn d4 you have to worry
about right so why just cannot hold on
to everything here and defend all the
weaknesses
uh what is better tactical puzzles or
calculation puzzles yeah i think it
depends on your level if you're i would
say if you're above 2000 then probably
calculation but maybe like below 2000
especially below 1600 i think it's more
important to be familiar with tactical
patterns
so i think it depends on your tactical
level like if you can do
if you're over 3 000 on chess.com puzzle
rush i'm sorry just.com tactical trainer
or something and
if you can get over 30 on like puzzle
rush
then i guess your tactics are pretty
good like you're able to see simple
patterns pretty quickly then i think
calculation is more important but
3 000 on chess.com tactics yeah i would
say that's kind of
yeah i mean that's i think that's that's
that's roughly equivalent to around 2000
tactical level in my estimation
um
and uh
yeah but if let's say you're like
below
below
unchested calm tactics and or um puzzle
rush you can't get past 20 then i would
say tactical patterns are still
something you would rather work on more
rather in calculation
um okay let's continue
um
okay so this was a game i played in
round two of the u.s championship uh
against john burke
young player who's lower straight but he
did really decently in the tournament
very dangerous young player
and
yeah we had a very interesting fighting
game
um
and um
we both had chances in this game
i would say
now there was um
now this was a very very interesting
moment right here
when i played bishop f6
my opponent here
um
played his move pretty quickly he played
rook c4 i guess he pre-planned it and he
played it kind of automatically
um
does anyone
see maybe a better move than than rook
c4 but but one thing though is about
this is you have to
you have to calculate um you have to
calculate till the end here
because uh it's uh
it's a bit uh
it's a bit on
it's a bit unnatural
sorry i yeah
that's it
yeah
i remember it now yes
very unconventional tactic that we we
both missed
yes salome yes i remember
yeah
queen c4 here
um queen c4 here i think it's
it's interesting the thing is i can
probably take on f3 here
uh maybe i don't have to take on c3 it's
interesting
you almost got it
i would say the better option is to
um
to take on e4
and originally i was thinking
i can take on c3
in retrospect the best moves probably
something a queen g7 which i also saw i
can do but i thought i can actually get
away with bishop c3 and john kind of
also told me that yeah he didn't think i
had anything but the thing is though in
this position white has an insanely
strong move
which is what move
which more or less wins the game like
it's
quite incredible
very very nice on unconventional move
it stops like blacks
one of black's key ideas
if you go e5 i think knight d4s
is kind of good for black
queen d2 does not work because of knight
takes e4 and then we attack the queen
and the bishop here
we need to make sure the knight on c5 is
not going to be able
yeah but then we lose our bishop
so yes we need we need to set up queen
c4 but in a way that our bishop will not
be attacked next move
so
ef rook f5 is what we both calculated
and then i think it doesn't really
do much
so this move in here is very nice
bishop a1 still 94.
if the knight can get c4
it's not that easy because then we have
rook a5 rook a1 ideas
queen c4 that's it yes because now the
knight is spinned and we're threatening
queen t4
and white is
winning it's a very nice
there might still be more to it but um
but the engine says white's winning so
this is yeah this is a very neat idea
that we both missed very nice
unconventional ideas so again we have to
be open-minded considering material
sacrifice like not automatically assume
some recapture
but then after he missed this there was
it was my turn to miss something later
in the game
so
oh you mean like here
oh because queen c4 pins the knight
right so
oh you mean queen c4 e instead of uh
well he does not have to take the rook
yeah that's the big thing yeah he does
not have to take the rook of course if
he takes the rook then yes
then this is very good for white
but he doesn't have to take the rook
here
so
fe you're trying to get him to take the
rook
oh that's the point because if you don't
take the rook it's there are some other
problems i think here like now you can
go to c4 and then the e4 pawn is weak
i mean it's a little complicated but
it's you know you can get the idea
okay you can always check this game on
on your own if you want it's in the
database my game against burke more
carefully
with the engine
but
and now it was my turn to miss something
so here
uh i'll i'll put the question to you in
a different way
what do you guys think about bishop c5
is that a good move or a bad move why or
why not
for white
well yeah i mean there are bishops well
bishop c3 i think is a a little
anti-positional because then we're we're
end up having stuck with a bad bishop
against the good knight i think
so that's i think and then our a5 puns
very weak so i think this would be
positionally just very good
so bishop c5 is a very interesting idea
we're trying to get a pass deep once so
what do you guys think about that move
very good yes somebody mentioned the
right the reason bishop c5 is not good
is because we don't you see the problem
is we automatically when we calculate we
automatically assume and recapture
somehow like that's just how the brain
works
and somehow i was not discipline that's
when he played bishop c5 i immediately
took on c5 i just somehow had a program
in my head that have to capture back
but i don't understand why i couldn't
stop for an extra 10 seconds and ask
myself can i do anything else think
about all the legal moves or at least
the captures and realized that i can
take on a5
and uh and that's just much better than
um
than taking on c5
and now white is clearly
black's clearly a little better in this
position even if he takes here here
y has to place something like rook b1
but
this is
i would say fairly awkward
so yes so this is another example of
being open-minded right not
automatically
don't automatically assume a recapture
bishop d6 we could play rook takes a5
and and something very similar happened
and uh
unfortunately in my
round
nine game
against uh sam shankland
so we had a very interesting uh opening
he found a very new idea
very interesting fight the possession
was equal but then he kind of went to
for a fight with bishop h3 and
n93 he instead of what instead of trying
to
force a draw he decided to try to play
in an interesting way
okay so the first question is here what
should white
do here after this knight a3 move
ah okay i see
okay so some people have have seen the
analysis okay then
then of course
yeah the correct idea is bishop a4 here
stop ignite c2 because knight c2 will
guarantee him at least a draw and then
he took on b2 and somehow when we both
calculated this we just assumed okay he
has to you have to take recapture on b2
in other words the rook is trapped like
how can there be
anything else right
but amazingly enough
black is not actually threatening to
take the rook because then we have
bishop a3 bishop f8 threat we regain the
knight and then we're going to win back
the exchange so bishop takes a1 i didn't
realize that it's not actually a threat
the position is very weird the knight on
a3 is like misplaced this position is
non-standard and whenever the position
is non-standard you have to approach it
also in a non-standard way you have to
be open-minded to look at
different new ideas
flexible ideas and it turns out that
even a simple move like knight d5
would give white a clear advantage right
because i don't want to take on b2 help
the rook get to b2 and help him get
counter play i would rather play a
waiting move
because now if he takes here
i will go here and uh
you know i can play
upper pawn here right and then
simply much better but the best move it
would be here bishop b3
uh
and the reason bishop b3 is better than
knight d5
and of course that's something that once
you see the idea that you don't have to
take on b2 automatically you know it's
possible for gm to realize that okay
like what are different ways i can play
and bishop b3 is better
because the knight does not always have
to leave c7 in some lines because here
this is clearly better for white just
upper pawn
and after this
if he goes bishop g7 the point is we can
take take and then we don't have to go
knight d5 we can play g4 with the idea
of rook d7 and
in some cases the bishop even gets
trapped like it's knight knight of four
idea
so long story short his best move here
is bishop e5 and even then you don't
take the rook immediately you go knight
d5 with the idea of 97 knight c6 and
some very interesting
very interesting tactics
for example if rookie 8
97
kick g7 knight c6
if the rook moves then knight e5
and rookie 5 the bishop b2 and pins the
rook so like white is just doing really
well everywhere but the thing is you
don't have to actually calculate all
that ahead of time you you just know
that at the li at least you could uh
at least you can take the rook that you
have that in your pocket you have that
extra pawn but then once you're here you
can say okay maybe i can do something
better and you kind of think again right
so the lesson is whenever
whenever the position is unclear and
like weird in many ways like uh unusual
you have to look for unusual ideas like
you it's a very important not to be very
disciplined and not just automatically
just go ahead and
recapture like just because the move is
obvious looks obvious looks like the
only move
like you should not just uh
kind of
you know um
do take it automatically
right so that's uh
that's the idea
and um and it takes a lot of discipline
right but that's why i suggest everyone
to when you play especially online or
the board try not to move within 10
seconds right try to you know think for
about 10 seconds to see can i maybe do
something else do i have to play the
move that i planned and the move that
looks obvious right even if it looks
like an automatic recapture like very
obvious
you know think for 10 seconds right it's
not gonna get you into time pressure but
it can help you find a lot of very nice
creative ideas
maybe a richard report i don't know i
think jeffrey jones is also very
creative because i never guess any of
his moves when i play him
so
uh
well no in in a blitz or in a blitz game
it's different right in the blitz game
it's reaction right okay and i'm not
talking about blitz game blitz game rap
10 2 or something rapid when you're in
time pressure it's different right so if
you have only like a two second delay
increment that's different like then of
course you this does not apply to that
right that's why for people who play
fast probably too much blitz might not
be good right because blitz can develop
these habits but what i'm saying is when
you're playing a classical game over the
board or something when you have time to
think and you have like an increment or
a delay that's at least like five ten
seconds
and you have a lot of time especially
early in the game there's no reason to
play automatically right you have to be
flexibly open-minded right and i think
you know if i would have won at least
one of these two games right it's
already a different term like i was half
a point away from first place right
so like i'm not saying i would have won
those games but like i had a good chance
to win at least one of these two games
if i just didn't play automatically and
what upset me the most is that i already
made a mistake like that against john
burke and then yet i had to make a
mistake like this again like
it's it's quite incredible because i've
never had this problem necessarily
before in my career at least it didn't
really show up and then in this one most
important tournament
there you there it happens
um what book do you suggest to go over 2
000 um
yeah i mean look that that's uh i don't
really like answering questions about
books because that's
um because that's something that uh
really just depends on what your
level is and your own strengths and
weaknesses are i think it's really very
individual things but
um
yeah that's why for me it's very
difficult to answer questions about
about books
um
i guess i'll show you one more a couple
of more that i planned for today
the game against ray robson i thought
was very interesting so i had like very
good prep like i
happened to study this line which was
kind of lucky
and you know at some point i even got
winning chances
but unfortunately i couldn't find the
way to
create the best winning chances and
and so here we have black to play and
the question is
uh what should black uh do here
black has a very nice creative way to
to get a very good winning chances
yeah h5 is interesting but h5 um okay it
threatens bishop g4 sure but if i go if
i go king e4 let's say which is
something i kind of want to do anyway
bring the king to e5
then i think that
it doesn't accomplish
its called bishop e3
uh i don't think it works because king
e3
if you want to take i take
rook c3 rogue d3
so it does not work
yeah oh okay
um
again it's a nice creative move and
think about in particular loose pieces
like this
in this case i could have and this one
actually i didn't rush like i didn't
play instantly i thought like 15 minutes
here because i was desperately trying to
find something
but i couldn't find uh yeah so the
knights on b3
and the knight here are loose pieces
right so there's an idea that kind of
takes advantage of these loose pieces
so
just
bishop takes d5 and then
if we do this the knight c5 is annoying
and then rookie five and then he's
threatening mate and he's getting all
sorts of counter play here this i didn't
didn't like yeah and i think somebody
suggested rook c4 rook c4 i think the
problem was
that
what was the issue with rook c4 trying
to remember
maybe it was takes take stroke d rook d6
or something
and um
bishop g4 king g3 and i didn't really
think it's that that amazing
bishop d4 yes
yeah cutting off communication and
somehow i just didn't see this move at
all like i thought for 15 minutes i just
didn't see it
right it's
and again this is a move that if i find
it's a i mean he was in time pressure
and it could have made him like very
nervous right objectively he should draw
this like it's like here
e4
and i give this check
i think it's like
king of two then i take then you find he
has to find rookie one otherwise he's
really suffering and then we get to some
rook end game like this
which the engine says is a draw but like
first of all he would have had to find
all these moves in time pressure and
then even still he needs to hold his end
game so
i would say yes like i if i was able to
be more creative i had a very good
chance to win one if not two of these
three games right and and that's and now
like now we're talking already about
like a plus three score right that's
even not counting like my first run win
my first round draw that i
didn't win a winning position right so
that's um
so it just goes to show right it's it's
important to extract lessons so
what i encourage you to do always is and
of course the most painful moment right
like the one against the the one against
fobby i'm not gonna really show you the
whole game right it's just too complex
and we're kind of running out of time
but i'll show you the the moment when
like i
i guess i could have
hoped to win
um
it was um
like at some point
yeah he found some very good moves queen
b2 and 95
and at some point i got very excited
because i thought here
here i i was i thought i could win with
rookie eight
and rook b8
and queen a7 and
i started having flashbacks of uh
varacobian against in 2017 when var's
winning move was also queen a7
uh in 2017 after when he made a
monumental comeback in that game
but the problem is there's knight d7 so
then i
and then i saw 95 like i thought maybe
this could be winning i thought wow
maybe this could be my
lucky day but then unfortunately for me
there was queen e5 queen here king f6
and somehow the stupid king escapes like
i don't have a check on d8 or something
and the king escapes and i spent almost
all my time trying to find something
here and i didn't and there was nothing
so i played king h1 which was which was
correct
but i guess i was already like i was
playing an increment here right and i
was already kind of a little bit upset
that didn't wasn't there for me and then
he played rookie five and he blocked me
and i guess i just got discouraged i
thought okay i'm not gonna mate him i
couldn't find anything and i just played
a passive like i played something rook
c8 and i and then i kind of lost the
threat and i ended up losing the game
but here white had an amazing sequence
of moves which
would have given me
very good winning chances which of
course five he missed this and you know
we all missed it it's just like
beautiful concept and unless it's so
hard to find even with a lot of time let
alone with time pressure right but it's
it again
symbolizes the
the story of my tournament like just not
being able to find
a creative unnatural move for the life
of for the life of me right and
this was like one last opportunity to
make it right and to find like the
brilliant move but
it didn't come to me and the thing is
the problem is it's not enough to just
find the move although i don't even
think i was considering moving the queen
away from like f2 square and whatever
but the problem with here is that you
have to find that
if queen of two there's this rook takes
e8 and somehow after this there's queen
h8 the rook locates that and that's this
queen a8 geometrical motif
they're just beautiful
and so that means he has to exchange the
queens and
play something like 93 and
and then of course only i'm playing for
a win here like i can't really lose here
and uh
like realistically i can only win this
and good chances i win this
and yeah so that was that was obviously
a
an opportunity although to find it in
time pressure
you know it's
was unlikely but
but yeah that was it was a chance
so as painful as it is right when when
you have a tournament like this when you
clearly see a weakness like a common
pattern and you see that it's always the
same thing like that's costing you in
many games you have to make note and you
have to really work on it right so if
you ever have a tournament where there
is something in particular that prevents
you from
you know from having you have a decent
result and prevents you from having
great results
you know that's that means that there's
something in particular you got to work
on
and that just means that you got to work
more and at home to train more regularly
at home because
ultimately
the
as they say
um you
you win the tournaments usually before
the tournaments no matter how hard you
try during the tournaments if you're not
maximally prepared then somehow
the game of chess
a lot of moves will not open to you at
when you really need it so that's why
you gotta really work earn it and
there's a reason wesley so wins so much
it might seem like he's not very
ambitious during the tournament but he
preserves his energy and but he he works
really hard
um at at home i remember i as as a recap
i'll tell you a story about wesley soul
which i think will be quite symbolic
of why he wins tournaments that
frequently
um
in 2016 after he finished his tough u.s
championship where he finished second
behind fabi
he tied with nakamura for second place
i talked to him and his
his mom and uh basically
he says that the very next basically the
very next day after he finished a tough
grueling tournament he was already
waking up up 6 a.m and working on
tactics
like the literally the very next day and
while other people are like drinking and
partying and relaxing and just trying to
get rid of the energy the very next day
he's already
thinking about the next tournament and
worrying about how to do
how to
uh play
better and uh
you know perfecting his chest right and
this is something that susan polgar
always talks talked about and continues
to talk about in
in our when i was at webster in our
chess training that if you really want
to be great like not just good but best
of the best you really have to um
put in your heart and soul not just
during the tournament but before because
everybody
tries hard during the tournament
but uh if you really want to be the best
and if you really want
the sort of sort of say luck
to be your way and the for you to really
be able to come on top compared to
the best players you really have to
put in your heart and soul every day and
be very disciplined like discipline
nothing replaces discipline like no
matter how hard you try during the
tournament if you're not disciplined at
home it's
you know there's gonna be
you're gonna have these feelings of
regret when
and you know there's nothing there was
nothing more painful
for me than
being on a closing ceremony and knowing
i had a chance to win the tournament and
watching these other people
go up on on stage right
um and uh you know it's
it might be it's so i i feel like it's
more less painful to train very hard and
kill yourself for the game of chess
almost
at home but then
then to have that deflating feeling of
not being not done not not having done
your maximum
um there's nothing more unpleasant than
having that feeling that you could have
you could have won and and you didn't
because of something that you didn't uh
do um
so um
so yeah that's that and i even made
myself for i just couldn't watch the
playoff right i just uh refused to watch
it i saw the games after but i purposely
scheduled the lesson
while the playoff was going on so that i
don't i don't watch it because feeling
would be
too painful
um yeah so anyway i hope this this is
instructive for you guys and if you have
uh if you're ambitious for chess please
learn from me like how how important it
is to be disciplined because
you know that disappointment is real
right and you don't want that to happen
to you
um okay i have
would say to succe that but be more in
touch with your yes of course you have
to trust your gut right so if you like
let's you know and i tell that to a lot
of my students so let's say you've
thought for like 10 minutes on a move
right
and uh you're not sure between two moves
you should try to go with the move that
you thought about originally because
that's more likely you got your gut
right especially if you're an adult
player who's been playing chess for many
years but somehow have a hard time
trusting yourself you have to trust your
gut because the god is correct 90 out of
10 10 100 times
but um what i mean is that when you see
a good move you know
explore all the possible moves right you
know it's uh don't only trust your
intuition especially in the beginning
right
um
do you believe in natural talent or do
you think um it's almost all if not all
hard work well i believe in both of
course right so if you have absolutely
no natural ability for a certain thing
you should probably invest more time
into something that you do have a
natural ability so if
if you see that as a chess player you're
trying very hard for for five years
playing and studying and working your
tail off and you're still 1200 but like
in basketball or something else you're
naturally more gifted you probably
should invest more into something else
right or whatever it is like
art or academics or you know whatever
else it may be i have to be practical
and smart right um you know so
but um
certainly you know we're talking about
people who already reached like gm level
right so everybody of course has who
reaches gm level has to be
somehow naturally talented right but
then what differs is like how hard
somebody works right
um
someone like sam shanklin you know
before he won the u.s championships he
was just working his tail off on a
regular basis right and that's why the
game of chess uh
gave back to him right it's like working
very hard with these jacob agart books
and
calculation like strains his brain right
that's
that's what you've got to do if you
really want to um
if you really want to be the best of the
best it's not just in chess and anything
and anything that you want to be uh
and anything like you want to be the
best at you have to try to put in that
effort so if you want to be let's say an
economics professor or teacher or a
doctor or a lawyer or whatever it else
may be you have to try to be the best of
the best to try to really uh you know
succeed in life right because there's a
lot of competition in any field right
so it's it's not just with chess it's
like like this and with anything in life
um
so let's see uh am i coming to london
anytime soon look i think uh
i think i decided for myself until the
pandemic is is over until we reach like
an endemic stage where you don't have to
deal with lockdowns quarantines where
covet is treated just like a
normal virus like a flu or a cold where
you can live a normal life even if you
have it like you don't have to sit for
two weeks somewhere and get stuck or
something and
and the borders being closed and all
these problems uh and people dying in
hospitals overflowing until that kind of
thing stops i'm just not gonna travel
out of the country you know so and
basically until the pandemic stage of
this pandemic is over i'm not traveling
out of the country that's that's i i
declined the world cup i declined the
great the grand swiss which you know
look like was on the verge of being
cancelled but looks like it's still a
goal but like yeah i'm just not i'm not
just not taking these chances there's
just too many good tournaments in the us
where i don't feel the need to
go out of my way and you know get
quarantine get stuck having to get
tested and god forbid i test positive
and then i'm stuck for for weeks and i
you know it's just
it's just too much for me right now
uh not worth it
so hopefully at some point hopefully by
the summer of next year i'll it'll be
better and then be okay to travel but
for now it's still it's like
um
i mean i'm comfortable certainly going
to places in the us and all these things
but um you know it's
but but yeah out of country it's just
too uncertain
um
yeah so we'll
see um
is it necessary to work on tactics most
of the time in order to get better
um
yes tactics the way i look at it is
tactics is like food for the brain so
you know without tactics you can't
really
uh grow as a chess player i believe um
you're gonna always limit yourself if
you don't work on tactics tactic is
something you have to do every day even
if you don't have time for anything else
you have to do tactics every day now you
should try to do other things as well if
possible but tactics is like the number
one requirement
um how do you develop in long
calculation and also being able to find
good candidate moves
yeah i think it's discipline i think one
thing that's important is making
candidate moves and not starting to
calculate deeply before you make a list
of candidate moves right because then
you can get sucked in into some
interesting lines and and
missing something simple and move one
for yourself or your opponent right so
as mark varatsky the late mark varietsky
would say
as long as you can see every you know
the main things on move one or move two
you're usually gonna have pretty good
calculation right so i think that's
general advice um
pretty common of course we all sometimes
fall on that trap and we start getting
analyzing something too deeply
yes um
and um
yeah but i think it's just a lot of
training and maybe if you feel like you
can get if you feel like you got stuck
somehow at your tactics or calculation
level maybe
uh if you have a coach that could be
something you can talk to them about
maybe
download the problems you get wrong and
go over them and see maybe there's a
pattern you're thinking that you need to
improve
because i know that sam shanklin for
example has
pretty much the way he got better from
like 26 20 level to like 2700 level he
worked with jacob agart
primarily on calculation right and jake
agard basically tailored problems
towards him and
he basically helped
sam realize how he needed to work on his
calculation and
and now he became just so good at it
right
and he became such a much better player
um so
okay um
is it possible that the seven game was
too exhausting no actually i was not
that exhausted about the game after the
game was an end game actually i always
felt fresh i physically somehow i always
felt pretty good like i don't think
physical stamina actually had to do with
uh
um my mistakes i think it's just like
i wasn't creative i think that's the
problem i wasn't
uh thinking the right way about moves i
wasn't thinking outside the box
uh yes i'm definitely disappointed not
to win i mean especially when plus two
wins and you score plus one it's very
disappointing it's it's when you have a
chance like
so many chances to win like just one
more game of course it's very
disappointing
what's the shortest time limit for an
adult improver to play regularly to
actually improve well i think it depends
on what their level is if you're an
adult improver and you're 1200 yes you
can improve very quickly to like 2000
level i think especially if you have
some natural talent and you're training
the right way if you're an adult and
you're 2000 trying to become 2200 it's
much harder it's going to take you much
longer so i think it depends on what
level you're starting and how much how
much exact time you're you're you're
training so again it's a very general
question hard to say
exact answer
all right i think it's time for me to oh
why is carlson so dominant what makes
them different is it natural talent or
hard work well i think both i think both
and i think
well there's actually i have one opinion
about carlson which is not something
that people say a lot but i'll say it he
very rarely drifts
during games like i've seen fabi choose
the wrong plan and like make a series of
bad moves i've seen wesley do it i've
seen hikara do it i've seen most elite
players do it i almost never see carlson
drift like carlson blunders sure
everybody blunders carlson could
misjudge some dynamics in a position he
can misplay an opening yeah he can do
these things but he almost never
you know just completely loses the
threat of the game like well i do it all
the time like all these other elite
players do it a lot well not a lot but
relatively speaking carls
maybe not tilt but just like losing the
threat of the position like just not
understanding like how to play a certain
position magnus on the other hand i
almost never see him like play series of
just bad moves in a row
like he could make a blunder yes but not
like showing lack of understanding of
the of the position like that's that's
the part he's just really really good at
like he's in that sense i think he's by
far the better player than others
but of course that's only one factor
right it's
um
all right well i hope that you guys
enjoyed this um and um i'll see you guys
next time
[Applause]
[Music]
you